dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shaughnessy here ever
thought about the fact that we have a
stupendously large amount of unlabeled
videos on the Internet and of course
with the ascendancy of machine learning
algorithms that can learn by themself it
would be a huge missed opportunity to
not make use of all this free data this
is a crazy piece of work where the idea
is to unleash a neural network on a
large number of publicly uploaded videos
on the internet and see how well it does
if we ask it to generate new videos from
scratch here unlabeled means there is no
information as to what we see in these
videos they are just provided as is
machine learning methods that work on
this kind of data we like to call
unsupervised learning techniques this
work is based on a generative
adversarial Network wait what does this
mean exactly this means that we have two
neural networks that race each other
where one tries to generate more and
more real looking animations and passes
it over to the other that learns to tell
real footage from fake ones the first we
call the generator Network and the
second is the discriminator network they
try to outperform each other and this
rivalry goes on for quite a while and
improves the quality of output for both
neural networks have the name generative
adversarial networks at first we have
covered this concept that was used to
generate images from written text
descriptions the shortcoming of this
approach was the slow training time that
led to extremely tiny low resolution
output images this was remedied by a
follow-up work which proposed a two
stage version of this architecture we
have covered this in an earlier two
minute papers episode as always the link
is available in the video description it
would not be an understatement to say
that I nearly fell off the chair when
seeing these incredible results so where
do we go from here what shall be the
next step well of course video however
the implementation of such a technique
is far from trivial in this piece of
work the generator network learns not on
the original representation of the
videos but on the foreground and
background video streams separately and
it also has to learn what combination of
these yields realistic footage this to
stream architecture is particularly
useful in modeling real world videos
where the background is mostly
stationary and there is an animated
movement in the foreground a train
passing the station or people playing
golf on the field are excellent examples
of this kind of separation we definitely
need a high quality discriminator
network as well and in the final
synthesized footage not only the
foreground and background must go well
together but the synthesized animations
also have to be believable for human
beings this human being in our case is
represented by the discriminator network
needless to say this problem is
extremely difficult and the quality of
the discriminator network makes or
raised this magic trick and of course
the old important question immediately
arises if there are multiple algorithms
performing this action how do we decide
which one is the best
generally we get a few people and show
them a piece of synthesized footage with
this algorithm and previous words and
have them decide which they deem more
realistic this is still the first step I
expect these techniques to improve so
rapidly that we'll soon find ourselves
testing against real-world footage and
who knows sometimes perhaps failing to
recognize which is which the results in
the paper show that this new technique
beats the previous techniques by a
significant margin and that users have a
strong preference towards the to stream
architecture the previous technique they
compared again is an autoencoder
which we have discussed in a previous
two minute papers episode check it out
it is available in the video description
the disadvantages of this approach are
quite easy to identify this time around
we have a very limited resolution for
this output video streams that is 64 by
64 pixels for 32 frames which even at
the modest framerate is just slightly
over one second of footage the
synthesized results vary greatly in
quality but it's remarkable to see that
the machine can have a rough
understanding of the concept of a large
variety of movement and animation pipes
it is really incredible to see that the
neural network learns about the
representations of these objects and how
they move even when it wasn't explicitly
instructed to do so we can also
visualize what the neural network has
learned this is done by finding
different image inputs that make a
particular neuron extremely excited here
we see a collection of inputs including
these activations for images of people
and trains the author's website is
definitely worthy of checking out and
some of the submenus are quite ample in
results some amazing some well a bit
horrifying but what assured is that all
of them are quite interesting and before
we go a huge shout out to LA flow
journalist who helped us quite a bit in
sorting out a number of technical issues
with the series thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time
[Music]